Now it's your turn to
write some media queries.
You'll be using dev tools to
make some changes to this page.
Inside the elements pane,
open up the head.
There, you'll find a style tag,
and inside the style tag, you've got
some breakpoints set up for you.
And it's here within the style tag,
that I want you to make your changes.
Simply right click and do edit as HTML.
And you'll be able to change it.
Apply style, so
that between zero and 400 pixels,
the background color changes to red.
And then between 401 and 599 pixels,
the background should be green.
And if the page is 600 pixels or
wider, make the background blue.
When you've set the right break points,
you'll see a code on the screen.
Type it in here to continue.
And by the way, you might find it's
easier to actually write your code in
a regular code editor like
Sublime Text and then paste it in here